you'll never walk alone das sagt der
bundeskanzler immer wieder um mit diesem
zitat aus der bekannten fußballhymne den
bürgern das gefühl zu vermitteln
wir kümmern uns die zeiten sind schwer
corona krieg inflation energiekrise
verbraucher und unternehmen sorgen sich
um den kommenden winter wie viel dieser
sorgen kann der staat wirklich nehmen
wie viel geld muss er an wen verteilen
werden die proteste zunehmend im winter
oder gibt es sogar eine chance für mehr
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft
deutschland im krisenmodus wie viel
staat muss sein unser thema in der
phoenix runde heute
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend herzlich willkommen
aus berlin ich darf meine gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist christina sie ist
2014 parteilose bürgermeisterin der
stadt spremberg das liegt im lausitzer
braunkohlerevier in brandenburg und sie
war auch mitglied der von der
bundesregierung eingesetzten kohle
kommission herzlich willkommen professor
marcel fritsche präsident des deutschen
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung und
professor für makroökonomie an der
humboldt universität in berlin ich
begrüße professor astrid lorenz sie ist
professorin für das politische system
deutschlands und für politik in europa
an der universität in leipzig und
herzlich willkommen eckart lohse leiter
der parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung vorher und je
spremberg hat 22.000 einwohner liegt ich
habe es schon gesagt mitten im
braunkohlerevier sie haben schon viele
veränderungen mitmachen müssen in ihrem
ort was ist es im moment was die
menschen dort bedrückt mit welchen
sorgen kommen sie zu ihnen als
bürgermeisterin also wir stecken
natürlich mittendrin im strukturwandel
und es ist auch wichtig dass dieses
große übergeordnete thema nicht verloren
geht in der aktuellen diskussion
das ist auch mir persönlich sehr wichtig
weil für die lausitz ist das eine große
chance dieser strukturwandel sie bekommt
eine aufmerksamkeit und das ist eine der
gefahren die ich als bürgermeisterin
tatsächlich sehe die bei uns vielleicht
noch und ob kommt dass durch die
täglichen sorgen und nöte der menschen
man sich so sehr fokussiert auf das was
am nächsten tag eventuell sein kann
dass der blick für die zukunft
vielleicht verloren geht und das ist
insgesamt schade ich bedauere dass das
hat nun seht jetzt gibt es punkte viele
sagen viele machen sich sorgen dass sie
ihre stromrechnung ihre gasrechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen können all das was
was bekommen sie da was wird ihnen
mitgeteilt ja so wie sie das gerade
gesagt haben das ist tagesgespräch
kleine stadt wenn die bürgermeisterin
durch die stadt geht wird sie da ganz
konkret darauf angesprochen da gibt es
solche sprüche ich kündige den
städtischen werken jetzt
die freundschaft obwohl die städtischen
werke noch der bester anbieter in der
region sind aber
[Applaus]
die sorgen gehen tiefer weil es sind ja
nicht nur die energiepreise das wird ja
ganz schnell existenziell es gibt erste
insolvenzen von unternehmen in spremberg
unser krankenhaus ist bedroht
alles das treibt wirklich ich würde mal
sagen jeden spremberger um und gibt es
was auf ihnen wird dann geschaut wer
soll denn helfen
ich sag immer die menschen wohnen nicht
im bundestag sie wohnen auch nicht in
den landtagen sie wohnen in der stadt
sie kommen natürlich zuerst zur
bürgermeister und auch zu den
abgeordneten aber unser blick von der
verwaltung von den abgeordneten muss
natürlich zu den ländern und zum
bundestag gehen weil die probleme sind
so gravierend die können nicht auf
kommunaler ebene gelöst werden im
gegenteil die gefahr ist doch da dass
die kommunen durch diese ganze krise
handlungsunfähig werden und das wird für
die menschen vor ort spürbar die fragen
mich wie können sie das absichern dass
die sozialen einrichtungen auch morgen
noch für uns da sind was können sie
dafür tun dass die mieter der kommunalen
wohnungsgesellschaft ihre betriebskosten
bezahlen können was können sie tun dass
unser krankenhaus aus dieser krise
heraus kommt und wenn es um die
antworten geht da habe ich
lösungsvorschläge aber ich brauche einen
handlungsrahmen dafür und den muss die
regierung vor geben sowohl die
landesregierung als auch die
bundesregierung wir brauchen schon den
start weil die probleme kommen nicht aus
der kommunalen ebene die kommen schon
von oben foto lorenz wenn sie das hören
was in früheren hier aus spremberg
geschildert ist das typisch also für
ganz viele unternehmen in dort ohne und
kommunen in deutschland sie sagen ja da
ist jetzt eine große erwartungshaltung
an den start das der jetzt einfach
helfen muss ja klar weil die kommunen
und alle die täglich durch die stadt
laufen ja unmittelbar spüren was die
sorgen sind da leute und wir haben zum
beispiel in einem forschungsprojekt mal
untersucht also was macht für die leute
ein gutes leben aus und wo sind sie
rolle des staates und
gesundheitsversorgung soziale dienste
und dann das gute und bezahlbare wohnen
sind absolut vorne und dafür würden die
leute auch selber geld ausgeben wenn sie
politische entscheidungsträger werden
und das steht dann natürlich ganz oben
und das erwarten sie auch vom staat
sicherheit zu geben also ich nicht in
diese persönliche leben zu weinen
begeben das wird jetzt nicht erwartet
aber sicherheit gewährleisten und dazu
gehört energiesicherheit gesundheit
sicherheit soziale dienste das ganz
unten im moment gibt es eine große
verunsicherung auf allen ebenen so lud
ja klar die kranken also wissen ja auch
nicht wie sie sich halten soll sie haben
sehr hart sehr plastisch beschrieben wie
zahlen sie eigentlich die rechnung und
wir wissen ja aus vielen untersuchungen
dass das die basis ist die mannschaft
also wenn es den leuten nicht physisch
gut geht oder wenn sie sich sorgen
machen dann funktioniert auch nicht
politische beteiligung gut funktioniert
nicht gut nächstenliebe all das was wir
ja auch brauchen unbedingt das ist
einfach die basis die basis dafür muss
der staat sorgen herr lohse erfüllt die
regierung wenn man schauen wir erstmal
auf die bundesregierung kann die diese
erwartungshaltung dann im moment
erfüllen angesichts all dieser krisen
die so alle miteinander auch zu tun
haben also ob am ende alle sagen ja ist
erfüllt und ich bin zufrieden dass
wahrscheinlich nicht alle das ist ja
jetzt schon klar auf der anderen seite
wenn man sich anguckt was diese
regierung in noch nicht einmal einem
jahr seit es sie gibt gemacht hat um die
erwartungen zu erfüllen dann muss man
sagen viel mehr geht nicht und würde
vielleicht den menschen dann ja auch
schon wieder angst machen also ich meine
alleine drei dieser entlastungspaket
daneben was die kleinigkeit von 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr auch wer
kein ökonom ist und wer mühen hat seine
heizungs rechnung zu bezahlen sagt sich
was kann der staat sich eigentlich noch
alles auf die schultern packen insofern
glaube ich das ist eine schwierige
balance viel weniger wäre schwierig
geworden zumal der viele maßnahmen noch
nicht wirken es geht jetzt mal gerade
los und september kommt diese 300 euro
energie geld das geht ja langsam aber
viel mehr würde ich die leute auch
unruhig machen weil sie sagen wie lange
tragen wir das eigentlich mit uns rum er
fragt ja wie sehen sie es als ökonom
kann der staat all das eigentlich
schultern und macht er es richtig gerade
im moment
der staat kann es schultern er muss es
auch schultern
jetzt mal als größenordnung die drei
entlastungs paket von knapp 95
milliarden euro an geldern versprochen
wirklich ein summen sind etwas kleiner
wahrscheinlich 70 milliarden euro in der
krone pandemie ballast 350 milliarden
euro davon waren damals hauptsächlich
unternehmen wir drücken muss helfen
einmal helfen usw
jetzt ist das problem ein bisschen
anders gelagert ist natürlich auch die
unternehmen die unterstützung benötigen
aber jetzt ist es eben eine zu höchst-
und soziale krise und gerade von den
menschen die sie gesprochen haben
menschen mit geringen einkommen haben
eine 345 höhere inflation wir sehen
nicht nur bei unternehmen die
existenzbedrohung sondern eben auch bei
vielen menschen das sehen die
privatinsolvenz rutschen wir haben in
deutschland 40 prozent der menschen die
nicht nur wenig einkommen haben sondern
keine ersparnisse haben die also nicht
sagen können ich nehme das jetzt mal die
4 500 euro mehr an kosten im monat und
nutzt das von dem ersparten und deshalb
glaube ich für mich nicht die frage kann
der staat es sich leisten sondern ich
frage sollte viel mehr sein kann der
staat sich nicht leisten zu helfen weil
als ökonom als wissenschaftler muss ich
ja nicht nur um was ist hier und heute
sondern auch es in fünf jahren und wenn
der staat eben nicht genug hilft
zahlreiche unternehmen pleite gehen
zahlreiche menschen in schieflage nun
zahlungsunfähig werden dann ist ja nicht
nur der schaden heute groß sondern ist
ja auch der schaden in fünf jahren groß
wenn unternehmen nicht mehr existieren
können sie auch keine steuern zahlen
also selbst aus der perspektive einer
soliden finanzpolitik muss der staat
jetzt geld in die hand nehmen um
unternehmen und vor allem menschen zu
helfen diese krise gut zu überstehen
hier kommt das an alle ist diese was
hören sie ist das ist dass die haltung
dass man sagt oli tun ja echt richtig
viel für uns
teilweise es kommt zu spät an es kommt
bei den menschen als ein großer wohl
wahr würde ich das mal bezeichnen wenn
sie das radio anmachen wenn sie den
fernseher anmachen da werden sie mit
einer vielzahl von vorschlägen
überschüttet sozusagen und es fällt dem
einzelnen dann schon schwer das für sich
wichtige herauszufiltern ich sehe das
auch als eine gerade in dieser zeit ist
eine klare und einfache sprache wirklich
nötig und wenn ich mir
spät abends dann die debatten im
bundestag anschaue dann denke ich was
macht das mit den menschen wenn die sich
das anhören wie man sich da an giftet
untereinander wir hatten 16 jahre lang
eine regierung die kann ja heute auch
nicht so tun als ob das alles keine
wirkung mehr hatte wir haben ein kanzler
der war vizekanzler gewesen und ich sage
ihnen die menschen sagen die müssen doch
in der lage sein sich zusammenzuraufen
in dieser situation es ist ja nicht
irgendein problem was mal auf doch das
ist existenziell das erwarten die
menschen von den politikern der
bundestag ist so voll besetzt wie noch
nie und auf der kommunalen ebene wird
das oft als kakophonie bezeichnet und
das macht es uns vor ort schwer wir
sollten etwas erklären wo die aufgabe
das zu kommunizieren aber bei anderen
geht also kommunikation läuft nicht so
gut irgendwo so gesehen wie sie haben
als ocean und darüber geschrieben über
die kommunikation von scholz & harbeck
ist in ihrer zeitung also wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt you never walk alone
das hat er mehrmals gesagt habe es
eingangs ja schon zitiert ist das sowas
wo man gibt man damit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern das gefühl ja wir sind echt
für euch da kommt es an sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche modelle gerade an der
spitze dieser regierung das eine modell
ist ein bisschen dass angela merkel
modell ich rede nicht über prozesse das
will ich auch gar nicht schon gar nicht
mit journalisten sondern wenn es fertig
ist dann sage ich euch das ist das
ergebnis und das funktioniert scholz
übernommen hat er ganz viel von merkel
übernommen ist passt aber auch zu seiner
art zu sagen so das ist es er versieht
das dann mit solchen floskeln also wie
you never walk alone oder was auch immer
hat
es im wahlkampf hat er gesagt respekt
einfach respekt so wird man das
verstehen die leute schon das ist eine
einfache sprache aber natürlich auch ein
bisschen unterkomplex in der
kommunikation so und der andere sagt ich
öffne sozusagen meine meine gehirn gänge
und er also robert habeck und lasst euch
teilhaben können genau zu gucken
wie das bei mir passiert das auch ich
schon mal eine sackgasse laufen oder
sowas gibt leute die finden das schön
ist natürlich viel anspruchsvoller dem
geben zu folgen ich glaube eine richtig
es ist ja auch keine einfache situation
und die wissen ja selber natürlich nicht
so ganz genau was müssen wir eigentlich
übermorgen oder vielleicht sogar morgen
kommunizieren also dass die russische
gas versorgung quasi auf null
zusammenbricht das können sie
kommunikativ nur wirklich schwer
vorbereiten weil es so unvorstellbar war
lange zeit das man natürlich erstmal
gucken muss das macht das mit kunst was
tun wir was erzählen wir den leuten oder
sie zu belügen also es ist schon ohne
sie noch mehr zu verunsichern ja modell
thomas de maizière wenn ich ihnen das
jetzt erzählen würde das würde sie nur
beunruhigen ja es ist schon sehr schwer
vor als würden sie sagen was ist eine
gute art
wo dass der staat sich erklärt dass es
irgendwie da ein dass man weiß wir sind
alle zusammen in dieser krise dass man
dieses gefühl also dass bürgerinnen und
bürger und die politik dass sie das
gefühl hat wir sind dass wir machen das
zusammen es gibt verschiedene
zielgruppen also die einen wollen
von den zumutungen genau wissen die auf
sie zukommen und die anderen wollen das
kennen wir aus vielen
meinungsumfragen einfache antworten die
die rufe nach der starken hand eine
person die klare antworten gibt ist dann
sofort da aber das passt ja eigentlich
nicht zur situation also wir würden uns
ja selber etwas vormachen wenn wir sagen
würden es gibt einfache antworten ich
finde das steht einer demokratie nicht
gut zu gesicht also wir sollten uns die
zeit nehmen bei solchen gravierenden
entscheidungen
wenigstens auch eine öffentliche debatte
zu führen gut dass es sie gibt im
parlament aber andererseits radio alles
zu lang für die einen braucht man die
klarheit der zumutungen und auch
alternativen die durch sortiert werden
und für die anderen braucht man dann
eine klare kommunikation dessen was dann
am ende als entscheidung heraus kommt
aber die
also ich würde noch sagen bei solchen
wichtigen entscheidungen und bei solchen
weitreichenden maßnahmen mit dem was
jetzt zu tun haben müsste man eigentlich
die menschen viel mehr einbezieht nicht
nur zu ihnen kommunizieren sondern sie
einbeziehen warum es werden ihre
positionen geräumt die lange typisch
waren für verschiedene parteien und das
ist auch in ordnung aber
die menschen die die parteien gewählt
haben in dem in den bundestag die haben
sie ja nicht für diese position gewählt
die positionen sind jetzt andere das
zweite ist es wenn neue position
entwickelt niemand hat mit dem ukraine
krieg krieg gegen die ukraine gerechnet
wir werden jetzt ganz neue politiken
entwickelt da muss man eigentlich die
leute einbeziehen und dann ist es so
dass wir über die typischen kanäle
repräsentativen demokratien parteien
mitgliedschaften ja weniger leute
erreichen mittlerweile viele sind da
nicht angebunden und ist greift massiv
ein oder betrifft massiv dass private
auch also auch die künftigen
generationen wenn wir uns jetzt
verschulden alles kann man gut begründen
aber man braucht das gespräch auch in
einer gesellschaft wird nicht nur im
bundestag
aber wissen sie meine erfahrung ist dass
das wirklich auf die einfachen fragen
des lebens zurückfällt ich habe einen
solchen beteiligungsprozess nicht zu der
energiekrise und nicht zum ukraine krieg
aber zu den großen
gesellschaftlichen thema strukturwandel
gemacht wirklich vor ort mit den leuten
und wissen sie was rausgekommen ist dass
die menschen sagen wir brauchen bildung
bildung bildung wir brauchen eine
vernünftige medizinische versorgung auf
dem land und wir brauchen eine
vernünftige moderne mobilität dass wir
pendeln können
dass wir die größeren orte erreichen
darauf müssen antworten gegeben und das
wird auch diesmal so sein darum machen
sich die leute sorgen
was wird mit dem gesundheitswesen und
kommt ihn in einer stadt wie spremberg
wenn dann das krankenhaus und in der
schutzschirm verfahren muss das kommt
natürlich mehr als zur unzeit aber es
ist auch eine folge der steigenden
kosten mobilität will ich gar nicht
drüber reden wir sind im ländlichen raum
was macht das mit den leuten wenn die
nicht mehr mit dem auto auf arbeit
fahren können es ist halt nicht da der
pnv diese großen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen diskussion
fallen bei den menschen immer wieder auf
die gleichen themen zurück und das ist
auch legitim weil die leute sind nicht
der staat sie haben das recht darauf
dass der staat die einfachsten fragen
beantworten das ist
meine meinung und das erlebe ich auch so
also ich werde immer zu diesen fragen
oder solche fragen werden mir gestellt
die großen zusammenhänge könnten wir
jetzt mitdiskutieren
aber das sind nicht die frage die das
gehört zusammen
was also man kann den euro nur einmal
ausgeben also wofür geben wir ihnen aus
und dann diese fragen zu stellen machen
wir jetzt e piano oder legen wir es mal
kurze seite wir brauchen jetzt gerade
meine rettung der energieunternehmen
oder so das ist doch eine diskussion die
geführt werden muss völlig legitim aber
dann gibt es auch immer was ganz schnell
die gerechtigkeitsfrage für wen gebe ich
das geld aus hervor wir haben wir jetzt
hört pnv wir hatten das neue euro ticket
das fanden alle gut das geht jetzt aber
dann doch irgendwie nicht weiter oder
vielleicht doch auf andere art also da
merkt man ja nun ganz starken ja dissenz
zwischen dem as was bei den bürgern und
bürgerinnen ankommt und dem was dann in
der politik entschieden wird also wo
nach und nach welchen kriterien wird
denn soll dann entschieden werden
na ja es wird nicht unbedingt nach
gerechtigkeit und bedürfnissen
entschieden also gerechtigkeit sowie wie
es als menschen als gesellschaft
definieren die über leistung und
bedürfnisse
und auch die entlastungs pakete zeigen
ja dass eben nicht zielgenau entlastet
wird also dass er per gießkannenprinzip
man versucht allen alle irgendwie
zufrieden zu stellen vor allem wichtige
klientel der parteien also jede partei
macht sein eigenes ding und ich glaube
die kritikpunkte in der sie ja auch
angesprochen haben anstelle dass die
politik jetzt handelt und wirklich
geeintes sagt hier wir haben eine krise
müssen schnell agieren hat man das
gefühl jeder versucht politisch kapital
daraus zu schlagen die leistungspakete
entlasten menschen mit geringen
einkommen verletzliche menschen die eben
in strukturen religionen leben die eben
nicht diese anbindung haben jetzt zum
beispiel bei der mobilität erhalten nach
für nach wie vor zu wenig unterstützung
als beispiel durch die drei
entlastungspaket dritten
entlastungspaket bekommt eine
vierköpfige familie mit wenig einkommen
35.000 euro bruttoeinkommen im jahr
vierköpfige familie ungefähr 1000 euro
entlastung wir wissen aber die haben
wahrscheinlich vier bis fünftausend euro
an mehrbelastung über energie über
heizen über
mobilität über nahrungsmittel und das
ist die problematik und viele haben
einfach diese zusätzlichen 4000 euro
mich also meine sorge ist die politik
hat noch nicht verstanden dass wir in
einer sozialen notlage sind und muss
nach wie vor es gibt ja auch erste gute
ansätze man muss sich auch alles nicht
kritisieren also zum beispiel die
ausweitung beim wohngeld jetzt mal ein
beispiel von 700.000 auf zwei millionen
ist ein ganz wichtiges ein gutes element
des dritten entlastungspaket aber es
kann eben nur ein erster schritt sein
weitere müssen folgen weil das was
bisher passiert lässt zu viele fragen
offen vor allem bei den energiepreisen
das bleibt der blinde fleck die neben
viele menschen umtreiben wie soll ich
meine meine stromrechnung wie soll ich
meine heizung meine heizung bezahlen und
das ist dann auch schwer
nachzuvollziehen herr lohse somit gerade
aktuell der streit um die gasanlage
jetzt die verstaatlichung des betriebes
juni per der ja mit der gasanlage
gerettet werden soll jetzt kommt bleibt
die gasanlage obwohl der betrieb
verstaatlicht das ist etwas was viele
leute auch nicht verstehen also nach den
gesprächen die ich gestern heute geführt
habe bin ich nicht ganz sicher ob alle
akteure schon genau verstehen
was sozusagen wie sie da raus kommen aus
einer verstaatlichung die ja nicht
morgen greift also man kann nicht sagen
wo prima wir beschließen das heute ab
morgen ist das ding staatlich und wir
nehmen einfach die gasanlage wechseln
und soll eine übergangszeit geben für
diese übergangszeit ist eine
finanzierungslücke da da muss man
wahrscheinlich mit dieser gasanlage
arbeiten es gibt unterschiedliche
positionen da kommt die parteipolitik
ins spiel das ist immer ärgerlich aber
wir sind eine parteiendemokratie
das ist blöd und doof aber natürlich
achten die auch auf ihr klientel und
herr lindner sagt sich natürlich also
bevor das alles bei mir gelandet und
nicht das steuer finanziere das wollen
wir der haarweg seine umlage machen und
da habe ich gesagt bevor ich das
anschließend alles vor meiner tür habe
dann könnte der lindner doch vielleicht
die 34 milliarden über staatsausgaben
nehmen es macht die sache nicht leichter
das macht die sache aber auch nicht
angenehmer für die bürgerinnen und
bürger bzw dann denken worüber reden die
ist genau das was vorher gesagt warum
bestreiten die sich darum wir haben ein
großes am leben und jetzt geht es dann
unter teil politiker aber wir sind halt
eine parteiendemokratie mit all ihren
vor und nachteilen werden natürlich es
gibt immer erzählungen irgendwie wie die
politiker wenn sie in china sind und
gucken irgendwelche großprojekte an
kommen aus demokratien und sagen was ist
schön siedeln einfach mal drei dörfer um
so die machen eine trasse für eine bahn
ist ja dass
niemand
uns will das also leben wir in den mühen
dieser parteiendemokratie das ist
mühselig oft ärgerlich oft klientel
politik aber ich fürchte auch nicht ganz
das ist doch unsere aufgabe in der
zivilgesellschaft in der wissenschaft in
den widder medien auf diese höchststände
hinzuweisen und die gasanlage über wen
das will ich auch noch mal betonen auch
wieder die verteilungsfrage es ist eine
politik die menschen mit geringen
einkommen sehr viel stärker belastet als
wenn der staat sagen würde wir nehmen
nicht dass über die umlage also von den
menschen sondern wir machen es über
schulden über kredite was dann im
prinzip der mensch mit stärkerem
einkommen ihnen direkt belasten würde
also auch da hat es eine
verteilungswirkung das ist meine große
sorge dass einfach zu viel im augenblick
gemacht wird was
die menschen mit wenig einkommen die
verletzlich sind wir stärker belastet
wirklich etwas haben sie aber natürlich
auch ein gerechtigkeitsproblem jemand
der investiert hat in den letzten zahl
der gesagt hat ich löse mich von gas von
öl ich mache alles was sie tun soll ich
habe solarpanels auf dem dach und so
weiter der ist plötzlich an dieser
umlage beteiligen ich kriege überhaupt
kein gas es brauche ich habe viel geld
investiert damit es nicht ist jetzt
werde ich dafür auch noch bestraft wo
ist da die gerechtigkeit welche bestraft
wenn er nicht bestraft
na ja gut aber meine wenn sie wenn sie
durch die die umlage auch bei
unternehmen die sozusagen beides
anbieten kommen die dann natürlich auch
mit rein wir haben im unternehmen als
sind also energie her schneller strom
über erneuerbare oder über kohle
erstellt verdient er richtig dicke
mauern blick über den strompreis und das
ist ja für mich eigentlich auch die
wieder wenn wir bei solidarität sprechen
die problematik hier wird gesagt hier
ist ein außergewöhnliches problem
außergewöhnliche verluste
jetzt bitte gemeinschaft ihr zahlt mal
alle es gibt aber viele energiekonzerne
die eben über strom über kohle über öl
oder über neue erneuerbare strom
herstellen und riesig gut verdienen weil
die strompreise durch die decke
geschossen und dann heißt es nämlich
aber die können jetzt bitte nicht
zusätzlich besteuern also hier werden
gewinne privatisiert verluste
außergewöhnliche verluste sozialisiert
und auch das widerspricht eigentlich
dieser idee der solidarität und
gemeinschaftlich durch die krise zu
kommen ich dachte was dazu sagen ja ich
wollte noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
wir nicht nur auf einkommen und
individuelle haushaltssituation
hinschauen sollten sondern auch darauf
was es mit orten macht sowie ihr
sprechen mag weil also zum krankenhaus
und
soziale orte die man haben muss das
betrifft ganz viele leute und da können
sie kann es ihnen sogar materiell gut
gehen aber wenn der arzt nicht
funktioniert oder wenn das krankenhaus
schließen muss dann betrifft das alle
also das ist eine wichtige und legitime
blickrichtung aber wir müssen auch
darauf schauen was das eigentlich mit
orten als ganzen mal ganzes macht und
wie wir sie retten stichwort auch
nahverkehr was sie sagen also das darf
nicht vergessen werden wir werden unser
krankenhausbetten dass wir uns wichtig
dass hier auch so sagen das werden wir
dann in unserer kleinen stadt unsere
kräfte bündeln da bin ich mir sehr
sicher dass das auf der ebene
funktionieren wird dass man sich da
einig ist und habe das steht jetzt an
allererster stelle auch wenn wir andere
investitionen auf den prüfstand stellen
müssen aber ich wollte noch mal auf das
gas und auch die erneuerbaren
zurückkommen
wirklich
betroffen sind ja diejenigen die auf das
versprechen gesetzt haben das erdgas
brückentechnologie und wissen wir wenig
brückentechnologie höre dann wirklich
zusammen viele jahre lang hieß es die
braunkohle wird die brückentechnologie
werden und wir haben in der kommission
das diskutiert und es war nicht konsens
gewesen dass
der weg ins gas dass der ausweg es
beziehungsweise die nutzung von erdgas
da haben viele gesagt das wird nicht
funktionieren
es ist aber suggeriert wurden erdgas ist
die brücke und da gibt es unternehmen
die haben darauf gebaut die haben
ungeschützt auf erdgas auch kommunen das
ist ein riesiges problem und die zahlen
jetzt noch die umlage oben drauf das ist
ein vertrauensverlust den können sie
nicht wegdiskutieren
die leute haben einerseits ja die die
kapitalkosten die müssen zins und
tilgung leisten für diese riesigen
anlagen die sie gebaut haben müssen
jetzt die horrenden preise dafür
bezahlen für das gas müssen die an die
bürger umlegen da sagt doch der normale
bürger kann das eigentlich noch wahr
seien
gut aber dass das in kohle gegen denn
natürlich besonders diskutiert und das
ganze erst einmal die leute verstehen ja
da was das ist verständlich aber sagen
wir mal so dass das mit dem gas so
ausgibt in einer solchen geschwindigkeit
bei allem was wir heute wissen über
blauäugigkeit umgang mit russland und so
weiter das war also der dramatik
natürlich nicht vorhersehbar im grunde
genommen hat es mit dem gas als
brückentechnologie natürlich eine ganze
weile funktioniert jetzt ist das modell
zusammengebrochen sind ganz
außergewöhnlich
widersprechen
wir haben zwei fehler gemacht in
deutschland den letzten 15 jahren nicht
mehr es bei uns sehenden auges in die
abhängigkeit russlands begeben haben
sondern dass wir den ausbau erneuerbarer
energien verschlafen haben denn wenn wir
heute 85 90 prozent erneuerbar hätten um
strom herzustellen
denn wenn wir sie nicht so betroffen und
deshalb auch das ist letztlich etwas
vergessen es in dieser krise wir gucken
ob das hier und heute und realisieren
nicht dass wir auch dieses problem
endlich adressieren müssen also viel
schneller ausbau erneuerbaren umstieg
bei den technologien auf andere
klimaschonende klimaneutrale
technologien und für mich ist das die
entscheidende frage ob unternehmen auch
in 25 jahren überhaupt noch
wettbewerbsfähig sind also nicht nur wie
können sie jetzt durch die krise kommen
sondern können sie sich behaupten im
globalen es gibt immer ausreden warum es
nicht geht der zweckverband
industriepark schwarze pumpe ist so
stolz darauf dass er zu den gewinnern
realer bohrer der energiewende gehört
ein wasserstoff kraftwerk mit
speicherfunktion was ein konventionelles
kraftwerk mit allen funktionen abbilden
soll da war uns versprochen dass auch
die regulatorisch damit erprobt werden
kann und wie ist es ausgegangen es wird
gedeckelt da wird gesagt beihilferecht
und wir kommen nicht voran ich sage
ihnen das ding hätte schon da stehen
können aber gibt es immer ausreden warum
etwas nicht geht wir sind auch nicht
innovations- als ausgeräumt lächelt
schnell frust und es gibt auch jetzt es
gibt ja schon einige proteste haben wir
vor allem auch in aus deutschland werden
die montagsdemos wiederbelebt da sowohl
von links als auch von afg seiten werden
sie organisiert freuen hier wird bei
ihnen auch schon demonstriert den
spieler ja also das war schon in der
korona zeit so das geht immer so in
wellen und im moment nimmt es wieder zu
das ist so ja auch in schramberg frage
und was bedeutet das jetzt wieder
menschen auf die straße gehen und wie
sollte man damit umgeht der protest ist
legitim gehört zu einer demokratie dazu
die frage mit wem stellt man sich
zusammen auf die straße und wo sind die
grenzen was ist nicht mehr in ordnung
also wenn es den die demokratie als
solche gilt oder gegen minderheiten ist
logisch dass eine grenze erreicht aber
grundsätzlich muss man sich damit
natürlich auseinander setzen und muss
das akzeptieren ich meine so einen
straßenprotest ist ja immer nur ein
zeichen das ist das führt nicht
unmittelbar selbst zu lösungen das heißt
nur hier achtung bitte das ist eine
wichtige forderung oder so ich finde ja
immer diesen schritt wichtiger zu einem
austausch zu kommen und ich würde mir
wirklich wünschen dass sie sprachen von
großen bundestag das wirklich die
abgeordneten auch sehen dass es eine
wichtige aufgabe jetzt wäre wirklich
überall vor der haustür im ganzen land
auch solche gespräche durchzuführen ich
sehe das gar nicht als aufgabe der
regierung und landesregierung oder
bundesregierung ich sehe das als aufgabe
der parlamente dies sind die orte der
wichtigen entscheidungsfindung über die
wichtigen gesetzespakete und ähnliches
und die sollten sich doch vielleicht
einfach noch mal ein bisschen stärker
als ich sowieso täglich machen sie sind
ja ständig im gespräch mit oft
interessenvertretern mit der breite der
gesellschaft noch mal treffen in
öffentlichen veranstaltungen auch um
symbolisch zu zeigen hier wir nehmen das
auch wir sehen euch ihr könnt ihr könnt
euch hier äußern oft ist das nicht ganz
einfach wenn dann protestiert wird der
wende wenn dann jemand von der anderen
partei kommt und einen wirklichen dialog
zu haben ist ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht
so ja das ist aber doch immer so das ist
ja sozusagen das gehört zur demokratie
dazu dass es schwierig ist mit
verschiedenen meinungen klarzukommen
herr los wer profitiert im moment von
diesen protesten
aufgerufen wird wird ja zum zum teil
also vor allen dingen von der hfg die
sozusagen auf einen heißen herbst und
winter hoffen ob sie davon profitieren
eben schon kurz gesprochen die umfragen
gehen moment gerade wieder ein bisschen
hoch aber das ist ja das ist ja sehr
volatil
die gesellschaft profitiert sicherlich
höchstens dahingehend dass diejenigen
sich ausleben können die da die da
protestieren gehen aber eine lösung
kommt man nicht mehr und die großen
parteien
können davon ja im grunde genommen
nicht profitieren
wie sollte das gehen von denen kommt
dieser prozess wird ja auch nicht
geschehen sollten arbeit wären gehen
eher dagegen naja man kann ja eben nur
aufklären erstaunlicherweise leben wir
jetzt in einer gesellschaft wo politik
so viel auf so vielen kanälen aufklärt
wie das noch nie die vorher der fall war
jede also der kanzler hat dann macht
instagram und der macht twitter und der
hat einen eigenen podcast und er gibt
interviews und so weiter also die breite
ist ja riesig nun kann man sagen was
habe ich davon wenn ich ein instagram
kanal habe ablassen das gibt es gibt ja
auch interaktive möglichkeiten
ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich was
bringt man hatte die verwirrung wird
eher grösser und die verunsicherung aber
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten sind mehr
denn je
also es werden signale ausgesendet
wichtiger wäre es doch dass man einen
austausch tritt bei so wie ich den
dingen für mich und das team von
verfassungs relevanz
sprechstunde mit bürgern ich meine dass
ein austausch da kann man nicht einfach
so und die abgeordneten sind alle 736
abgeordnete also wenn sie ihren job
ordentlich machen dann reisen sie
permanent in den nicht sitzungs zeiten
in ihren in ihren wahlkreisen rum und
machen bürgersprechstunden gehen da hin
ich weiß nicht was sie das unbehagen ist
doch groß weil viele bei solchen termin
ja nicht da sind viele sind tagsüber da
arbeiten die leute oder sie sind nicht
organisiert und gewerkschaften hat im
osten gewerkschaftsmitgliedschaft ist
nicht so verbreitet oder in parteien
oder so das heißt da fehlt die
schlüssige sozusagen anbindungen an
diese interessen kanäle wie sie typisch
sind für die repräsentative demokratie
und das müssen einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen ich auch nicht gut aber irgendwie
müssen wir jetzt in solchen besonderen
situationen wie jetzt mit solchen
enormen enorm wichtigen und
weitreichenden entscheidungen müssen wir
glaube ich einfach noch stärker
versuchen wirklich
nicht nur das tagesgeschäft zu machen
sondern darüber hinaus auf die leute
zuzugehen und nicht nur an sie zu senden
sondern mit ihnen zu sprechen oder etwas
zu machen was seht was ihnen hilft ihre
rechnung zu bezahlen ganz banaler
fratzscher ist das wie sollte die
politik auf diese proteste reagieren
indem sie handelt natürlich sind
gespräche gut aber die lösung liegen auf
der hand für die allermeisten menschen
heißt es jetzt erst einmal kurzfristig
sie brauchen ganz konkret hilfe
finanzielle hilfe es gilt viele
unternehmen es gilt aber eben auch für
viele menschen mit mittleren und
geringen einkommen und da muss die
bundesregierung jetzt erstmal den
internen konflikt lösen und sagen wo wir
mal die prioritäten setzen
schuldenbremse als heiligtum oder will
man sagen mein jetzt ist die zeit wir
haben eine notlage man kann die
schuldenbremse aussetzen man kann den
menschen helfen es gibt kein staat in
der welt der solider gehaushaltet hat
der glaubwürdiger ist er sich günstiger
auch finanzieren kann weil man ja auch
bei corona gemacht hat der erfahrung von
kohle würden sie jetzt auch sagen es ist
wichtig dass jetzt noch mehr geld in die
hand nimmt
absolut und wir haben ja auch in der
korona krise gelernt was funktioniert
und nicht funktioniert es gab ja
durchaus einige paket wo man gesagt so
ist es nicht da gibt es missbrauch aber
es hilft niemand und wir könnten doch
jetzt die lehren daraus anwenden und
auch ganz konkret sagen unternehmen
erhalten hilfen je nachdem wie hoch ihre
umsätze sind relativ zur strom- und
gaspreisen das gleiche gilt für
bürgerinnen und bürger man könnte bei
den unternehmensinsolvenzen die
antragsfrist unternehmensinsolvenzen
eine zeit lang aussetzen man kann
liquiditätshilfen geben also wir haben
doch erst eine große krise gehabt und
wir wissen was funktioniert aber dafür
wieder der politische wille also ich
glaube was zu tun ist das ist nicht so
sehr das problem obwohl ich dialog
natürlich total für gut befinde aber
jetzt ist doch wirklich entschiedenes
handeln wichtig und vor allem schnell
denn noch mal für mich aus der
ökonomischen perspektive entsteht der
große schaden weil niemand im augenblick
planen kann wenn ich jetzt eine bäckerei
habe oder ein kleines mittelständisches
unternehmen ich weiß doch gar nicht
welche energiekosten muss ich rechnen
jetzt mit der inflation weiter und diese
sicherheit planungssicherheit ist so
wichtig um einigermaßen die krise kommt
ich würde entschieden widersprechen dass
klar ist was zu tun ist es ist das ziel
vielleicht klar aber nicht mehr weg weil
die nebenwirkungen der maßnahmen die wir
jetzt treffen muss man doch einfach auf
den tisch legen und diskutieren und dann
kann man ja trotzdem bei den massnahmen
bleiben wenn sie gut begründbar sind
aber das gehört doch dazu
und das ist doch nicht eindeutig muss
der richtige weg wäre na ja doch wenn
man jetzt sich anschaut menschen mit
mittlerem einkommen finanziell zu
entlasten zu sagen sie haben als vier
personen haushalt mit wenig einkommen
4000 euro an zusätzlicher belastung dass
der staat sagt wir helfen ihnen das
jetzt 3000 sind oder 4000 2000 kann man
über die größenordnung steht aber dass
man dort helfen ich finde im augenblick
ist es sogar relativ klar was zu tun ist
und das gleiche gilt für unternehmen
klar bei der ausgestaltung man bereit
ist so viel geld auszugeben und eben
nicht die schuldenbremse einzuhalten
der ehemalige bundestagspräsident
schäuble hat in dem interview gesagt
also auch nach der frage nach dem einem
angst vor allem mut winter auf unsere
demokratie das aushält die folgen halt
eben auch dieses wirtschaftskrise hat er
gesagt wir haben uns leider zunehmend
eine mentalität zugelegt in der der
staat die menschen betreuen muss auch
aber bürger haben eben auch pflichten
als staatsbürger um demokratie ist auch
eine zumutungen an einer demokratie ohne
demokraten gibt es nicht also diese
mentalität dass der staat immer für
alles sorgen muss von hand hier ist das
empfinden sie das auch so ist das die
mentalität der ist das so in teilen ist
das so aber
nicht flächendeckend also aus dem aus
dem leben wir haben gerade einen
handwerker im haus und mit dem wird dann
auch also so ganz klassisch
bürgermeisterin und bürger wird das auch
diskutiert und der sagt ganz klar er
würde sich nicht
darauf verlassen
finanzielle hilfen in anspruch zu nehmen
er will weiter sein seinen job
wahrnehmen und was macht das dann aber
mit den menschen wenn die seen
diejenigen die für sich selbst sorgen
wollen das ist ja ein hohes gut wenn
jemand das will nicht wenn er selbst
bestimmt ist ja man kann hilfen in
anspruch nehmen da bist du eben nicht
wirklich selbst bestimmt aber wenn die
dann die gefahr sehen dass das nicht
mehr möglich ist dass der job wegrutscht
dass die rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlt
man kann dann wird es eng gerade in
ostdeutschland weil das haben wir ja in
den 90er jahren durchgemacht und ich
sage ihnen das ist keine einfache
erfahrung gewesen und die sitzt auch
tief drin deshalb würde ich das auch
sagen man muss jetzt in dieser
besonderen situation muss man handeln
auch wenn es weh tut aber dann tut es
nur im portemonnaie weg und nicht
woanders und das wäre mir sehr wichtig
dass es nicht woanders weh tut dann tut
es eben nur im portemonnaie b aber bitte
an den richtigen stellen eben nicht nur
aufs eigene portemonnaie shows und eben
dann auch die großen zusammenhanglose
wie sehen sie dass diese diese die so
rundum sorglos mentalität der staat muss
man für alles sorgen ist es etwas was
gewachsen ist und würden sie daher
schreibe zustimmen dass der dass der
auch bürger mehr pflichten
wahrnehmen muss also das gilt natürlich
immer dass sie sagten vorhin der bürger
ist nicht der staat letztendlich ist
natürlich schon die entität der bürger
sollte der staat sein aber der einzelne
der jetzt vor der frage steht nicht muss
ich irgendwie 5 prozent mehr gas
rechnungen bezahlen sondern muss sich
ein ex paares dessen bezahlen was ich
jetzt habe und bin ich anschließend
dahin sei es als unternehmen sei es als
privatperson dem hilft das natürlich
nicht der bräuchte im grunde genommen
die zusage
weiß ich was einen könne nicht 300 euro
nach einem halben jahr warten einmal
sondern im zweifelsfalle braucht er 3000
euro über den winter als privatperson
und als unternehmen noch was ganz
anderes da sind sicherlich große
unsicherheiten da
und die bereitschaft im grunde genommen
ist glaube ich hoch von den menschen zu
sagen wir versuchen auch durchzuhalten
wir haben ja noch nicht so was sie eine
breite unruhe das ist ja dann wir haben
kein geld besten bewegung im moment dies
auch übrigens über energiepreise
entstanden frankreich also die gefahr
ist grundsätzlich bei den franzosen
etwas höher als bei uns ist es
friedlicher ich glaube die die
bereitschaft mitzumachen
eigenverantwortlich zu sein ist schon
ganz ist schon ganz gut aber
da können natürlich auch situationen
entstehen wo die ganzen ankündigung aus
dem sommer und heizen wir diesen winter
mal nicht jetzt september ende september
morgens um fünf grad
schmallippiger und denken okay was ist
denn eigentlich gleichzeitig die post
vom gasversorger da kommen natürlich
leute die sagen das halte ich keine drei
monate durch und da müssten natürlich
müssten die wissen ich kriege 1 entweder
auf sehr einfachem niveau ein kredit
oder eine staatliche zusage oder sonst
irgendwas was wir zumindest meine
existenz sichert das ist glaube ich noch
nicht soweit da gab es mal so ne also
eine richtig krach maßnahme weil dieses
neuen euro ticket was aber natürlich nur
menschen geholfen hat war im bus
irgendwo in der nähe war und wenn ich
auf dem lande bin und muss sowieso 40
kilometer pendeln am tag dann habe ich
möglicherweise auch nicht unbedingt ein
heiliger den kleinen kratzern zu hause
naja aber der tank rabatt hat den preis
dann auf eur 90 4 liter diesel oder so
was ihr denkt ich jetzt brauche noch
kein sport preis
von da her da sind schon situationen wo
man sagt da muss noch was deutlicheres
kommen das glaube ich auch ich sehe aber
nicht dass ist jetzt so eine massenhafte
mentalität gibt ich will jetzt nicht tun
nichts mehr selber ich bin nicht
leidensfähig sein ich will nur vom staat
also wir haben wir haben auch in unserer
forschung gefragt was sind denn die
dinge die wichtig sind für das fürs
leben von gutes leben und was davon soll
der staat eben machen und bei vielen
dingen sagen die leute gar nicht das
soll der staat machen also insofern ist
sozusagen so ein rundum sorglos paket
vom staat erwartet wird kann ich jetzt
sozusagen forschungsbasierte nicht
bestätigen und dass man sich wünscht
dass man in einer wahren wohnung die
bezahlbar ist wohnt ist ja an sich etwas
ja bescheidenes also das soll gehört ja
eigentlich zu den grundbedürfnissen dazu
ist nichts was jetzt neu ist sondern das
war schon immer so aber es kostet halt
unter den jetzigen bedingungen irre viel
geld dass abzusichern das ist aber nicht
sozusagen dem geschuldet dass die
menschen jetzt mehr wollen sondern sie
wollen immer noch das gleiche wie immer
sie wollen einfach ein gutes und und
bezahlbares leben warme wohnung und wir
haben ja auch erfahrungen in der
gesellschaft mit großer solidarität ob
das in der korona zeit war vor allem am
anfang ob das bei ereignissen wie bei
der flut im aartal war ob das bei der
aufnahme von ukrainischen flüchtlingen
war das das da gibt es ja genug zeichen
hält das heft gibt es glauben sie dass
die gesellschaft so oder so ist das auch
jetzt mit dem krieg in der ukraine wenn
das jetzt noch viel länger dauert so wie
es aussieht dass diese solidarität hält
und dass man auch weiter bereit ist zu
sagen okay dafür zahle ich dann auch den
höheren gaspreis
ob es hält hängt von denen ab die
führung im land übernehmen von der
politik auch von unternehmen und auch
wieder wissenschaftliche studien die
eindeutig sind gesellschaften die hoch
solidarisch sind aber die die
schwächsten mitglieder
letztlich sind mitglied ob das jetzt
unternehmen einzelpersonen schützt
kommen durch große krisen ob das kriege
sind pandemien sind naturkatastrophen
wirtschafts und finanzkrise deutlich
besser und zwei wirtschaftlich sozial
politisch und das immer wieder bewusst
zu machen wenn es hier um solidarität
geht es nicht nur darum den am stärksten
betroffenen zu helfen sondern es ist im
interesse aller denn man kann es ja
durch rechnen wenn jetzt uns die
unternehmen pleite gehen und menschen
abgehängt werden nicht mehr arbeiten
oder nicht man die maße arbeiten können
weil der handwerker eben nicht mehr
nicht mehr das geld hat das zu tun damit
steht er nicht in der person ein schaden
sondern uns allen entsteht ein schaden
dann wird auch die wirtschaftliche
erholung nicht so gelingen und hier das
bewusstsein muss er da sein das
bewusstsein muss da sein aber das muss
natürlich auch vorgelebt werden und wenn
die politik also deshalb ich bin dabei
schwer mit demokratie streit ist da ein
teil der demokratie aber in solchen
krisenzeiten wirklich ein klares signal
zu setzen und sie haben es angesprochen
in der ersten phase der pandemie gab es
diese solidarität da hat auch die
politik zusammengestanden schnell
gehandelt und das würde ich mir auch
jetzt in dieser krise wünschen weil das
wichtig ist um eben diese krise
abzumildern und wirklich schnell
durchzukommen vielleicht ein großer
unterschied zum beginn der korona
pandemie tatsächlich da standen alle
sehr zusammen aber da war die situation
dass viele menschen das so wahrgenommen
haben wir wissen jetzt einfach nicht wie
wir da rauskommen wenn ich nein
irgendwie in der impfung erfunden wird
oder so was also es gab keine
alternative im moment ist es bei einem
teil der menschen doch so und der teil
ist nicht klein dass sie denken es gibt
eine alternative sondern man muss
einfach nur die russland sanktionen
aufheben und dann wäre alles ganz
einfach
ein unterschied zu den beginn der korona
pandemie und deshalb muss man muss man
die argumente einfach immer wieder ins
volk tragen so zu sagen wie verteidigen
wir unsere werte wofür machen wir das
und das begründen warum jetzt diese
maßnahmen notwendig sind und eben auch
ernst nehmen dass es jetzt anders ist
als am anfang der korona paris sind
andere rahmenbedingungen hier feiern
hier wie sehen sie zu wie viel
solidarität zusammenhalt kriegen sie
organisiert in ihrer kommune also das
will ich will gar nicht vorstellen dass
es den zusammenhalt nicht mehr geben
würde das würde wirklich die grundfesten
erschüttern
das kostet auch in einer stadt wie
spremberg etwas da kann ich jetzt noch
kein preisschild dran machen aber ich
weiß dass es uns etwas kosten wird wir
werden andere dinge die wir uns
vorgenommen hatten auch den prüfstand
stellen müssen aber das ist eine große
aufgabe der
kommunalpolitik die das ja nicht
verursacht hat genau das vor ort zu
leisten weil noch mal die menschen sind
bei uns der zusammenhalt wird in den
kommunen gelebt und die kommen auch die
kommunen müssen von der politik in die
lage versetzt werden handeln zu können
wenn die reserven der stadt spremberg
und wir haben reserven aufgebraucht sind
und wir rutschen in die
haushaltssicherung dann darf ich diese
freiwillige leistung gar nicht mehr
machen auch das gehört mit dazu das ist
eine situation da kann man ist wie mit
dem beihilferecht nicht es gibt
situationen da muss man auch mal etwas
in frage stellen und handeln und sagen
das darfst du jetzt weil man kann die
untere ebene auch nicht damit alleine
lassen das muss dann schon wirklich der
staat leisten das ist meine erwartung an
die regierung sowohl land als auch
buntes muss der natur ganz konkrete als
letzte frage machen sie sich sorgen
jetzt vor diesem winter oder denken sie
wir kriegen das schon ganz gut hin wir
werden das hinbekommen wir werden das im
übrigen auch deshalb hinbekommen weil
ein großteil der öffentlichen gebäude
und der wohnung in spremberg mit
fernwärme aus kohle strom beheizt werden
auch das gehört mit dazu
sie wissen ich bin eine verfechterin
ausstiegsdatum 20 38 aber wir geben auch
ganz viel gas in richtung erneuerbare
energien ich denke für spremberg
bekommen wir das hin aber es wird
abstriche geben müssen das ist jetzt
schon klar okay viel erfolg dort ihnen
danken vielen dank herr fried china
verloren herr lohse für das gespräch und
fielen dagegen fürs zuschauen heute
abend bei der phoenix runde bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]